Marjorie Taylor green going from One
Lunatic extremist Republican in Sarah
Palin to
another lunatic extremist Republican and
Marjorie Taylor green Marjorie Taylor
green says listen
it's okay that I believe things that
aren't true because lots of my followers
believe things that aren't true these
are my words not hers my guess is she
would put it a little bit differently
but let's listen to what Marjorie Taylor
green had to say on this it looks like
the it looks like this program is from
the 90s night talk is the name of the
show
check this out
thank you the Atlanta paper tells me
about 10 days ago you were still in
session at a trump rally in Arizona that
Trump was won the 2020 election and it
says if you are one of his biggest
allies
I am always proud to support president
Trump Judy I'm so grateful for the way
he led our country with his America
First policies I miss them very much
being our President and so do a lot of
people and I do I say all the time I
really feel like he won the state of
Georgia and I feel like he won the state
of Georgia now
is there a factual basis there no but
she guys she feels it and I do think he
won the 2020 election but you want to
know something it's okay for me to say
that because a lot of people feel the
same way right
this is actually super important
they justify their investigations and
their claims about the 2020 election by
saying lots of people feel this way lots
of people believe this but the reason
that lots of people feel that way and
believe it
is because people like Marjorie Taylor
green told them that it's true now I'm
not excusing anyone right it's not if
Marjorie Taylor green told me Trump won
I wouldn't believe it unless I had
actual evidence that suggested that but
it's a vicious circle this is like the
Marco Rubio Dropbox thing last week or I
think maybe it was the week before at
this point uh senator from Florida Marco
Rubio who's a republican he's running
against Val demings Val demings is a
democratic congresswoman who now is
running for Senate and one of the best
debate performances by the way was that
by Val demings but there was a certain
point when the topic of election
Integrity as they like to call it came
up were Mark or Marco Rubio said well
listen
there's two reasons why we should be
against these ballot drop boxes one
someone could bomb the ballot Dropbox
which hasn't happened and it was
interesting that he was giving people
that idea and he said the second reason
is people don't really trust the ballot
drop boxes but at the time we said well
why don't people trust the ballot
dropboxes because Marco and others are
telling them they aren't trustworthy
so is that really can you really use a
belief you created as a reason why
something should change in the way you
want it to change this is like a TR when
Trump says a lot of people are really
angry about what happened in 2020 and so
we have to look into it well they're
angry because you lied to them and made
them angry based on things that aren't
true claims that are completely debunked
and
um if you apply this I mean imagine that
Marjorie Taylor green or whoever said
listen I think Jews will not replace us
is a really important thing for us to
talk about because a lot of my
constituents feel the same way they're
worried about the Jews replacing us so I
think it's an it's a totally logical
thing to talk about we wouldn't accept
that at least many of us would not maybe
some of Marjory Taylor Green's followers
would so understand that they use the
beliefs they created in others to
justify their continued Pursuit and
further lies about these issues it's an
endless Circle there's this term
docsastic closure that is sometimes used
to describe this where there's you can't
your Universe reinforces the very
beliefs you are in this is often the
case with religious beliefs and I know
that some in the audience may not like
this analogy one of the things that
often happens with religious beliefs is
people say
here's my beliefs because this is what
my sacred texts tell me to believe and
so they are true
and then you say okay what evidence do
you have that these sacred beliefs are
really sacred beliefs given by God they
say well the sacred texts themselves say
that they are sacred
and then you try to exit the bubble and
say right but what do we have from
outside of that that tells us these are
the sacred beliefs given by God
they don't have anything but it doesn't
matter
the very claim within those sacred
beliefs is self-perpetuating by virtue
of saying these are the sacred beliefs
of God and you can't pierce it but you
sometimes you can but it is very
difficult to pierce it same type of
thing with this voter fraud stuff